stop just wait before you buy the
overpriced n-series GPU because a much
better option is coming out really soon
from Nvidia this new series is codenamed
ampere and it is expected to be revealed
at the end of March at GDC and released
on April 12th so like I said it's very
close but why should you wait for it
well it should bring with it a
significant price drop and even if it is
still overpriced then you still get more
performs for the same price that you
guys are willing to spend right now so
this is definitely a much better value
but honestly I think that these cards
will likely bring a price drop because
miners will be taken out of the scene by
Turing and as a result the only thing
still inflating prices would be did
demand put on by gamers and increased
RAM prices so most likely prices will
drop but that's not it these GPUs should
also bring with them much better
performance some things that we can
expect will most likely be GDD are six
memory at speeds of 16 bits per second
or 18 gigabits per second also these
cards should be produced in the 12
nanometer architecture so that's a plus
as well that's all great in stuff but
what does that really mean for gaming
performance well there isn't really any
SPECT leaks or crazy rumors out there
about extreme performance either so it's
really in the dark but we can hope that
video matched the same performance
upgrade that they offered last
generation in last generation the 1060
was about equal to 980 the 1070 was
equal to 980 TI and the 1050 and 960 and
so on and so forth so we should be able
to see something similar with
generations as well for example the 2060
should be equal to the 1080 the 2070 and
the 1080 TI and so on and so forth
even if ampere doesn't bring that much
performance that 2070 well at least be
as good as a 1080 TI so nonetheless this
new series will bring good value to
market right now if you guys are like
Nvidia want wouldn't want to give away
too much performance because they have
no competition and you have to remember
that Intel is going to kill the GPU
market so NVIDIA has to be alert know
but on a serious note this type of
upgrade is really not that much
considering what NVIDIA has in their
store NVIDIA has much superior
performance available to them which can
be seen in their extreme GPUs like full
tow series with its like 21 billion
transistors and hundred teraflops or
whatever it is so it really isn't that
much for Nvidia nvidia already made sure
to not give us too much performance by
not giving us volta and making this just
a Pascal refresh so I don't think me
Nvidia will skimp out even more on
giving us performance overall the
performance upgrade coming from ampere
should be quite significant and more
than enough to wort upgrade and
definitely enough to just weigh a little
bit more the MSRP for the 2070 should be
at about 379 just like the 1070 but as
we all know to demand and the RAM price
will probably make it about 500 to $600
but that is still much better than
buying a 1074 over $500 or whatever
crazy price they are right now these are
getting much more superior performance
per dollar also if you guys are patient
for just a few more months after at
least until about June or July then
you'd really get a much better value by
then the initial price for these new
cards and demand would have dramatically
died down and really the only thing that
would be inflated prices will be the
increased prices of RAM
but at that point you should be able to
get ten twenty seventy four about four
fifty dollars which is pretty much like
a gtx 1080i for a hundred and fifty
dollars less so it really does make a
difference and if you guys can afford
even more then you are still benefiting
from this but again you're getting much
more better performance for the same
price so i really recommend that you
guys just stay patient to see what
ampere will bring if you guys are
interested in a more detailed analysis
of how much I think ampere old cost and
if it will cost a mind-boggling fifteen
hundred dollars then make sure to check
out my dedicated via about that but
that's pretty much all I have to say so
please just have a little bit more
patience but it's really unwise to buy a
graphics card right now and there's a
much better option coming out very soon
but anyways
make sure to post down below what you
guys are thinking for example do you
think ampere will reduce prices and what
do you guys think about curing I read
all my comments and I'm curious as to
what you guys think so make sure to post
your thoughts down below also guys if
you guys like this video then make sure
to drop a like and if you would like to
see more videos just like this then make
sure to subscribe and hit that Bell
notification if you want to be notified
every time I post a new video but until
next time
[Music]